thomas malthus a famous 18th century
economist famously wrote that
most of human history there was no
growth in fact there could not be any
growth because as soon as you started to
make more food what would happen
your children would survive
you'd have more sex
have more children
as we all do when we eat too much um
there's the 18th century things change
and uh
then suddenly you gobble up
all the excess food
so that's what this graph is this graph
of world gdp per capita this is what the
graph is over here it's not world gdp
which is a measure of all the economic
activity but the world gdp
per person
now i know if you're anything like my
history students at cornell you hate
math
but a little math goes a long way so i
don't how many of you are frightened of
math
well san francisco is a different crowd
y'all are like pro okay math it's matt
it's on all right
so if you look at this graph
i want you to look at the year zero or
one or whatever
467 now
467 dollars per person in the whole
planet now do you think that's totally
accurate no probably not but it gives
you a rough
don't be touching my beer all right
all right
okay this is a rough sense
go to 1000 a.d 450.
roughly flat
if you extend this graph back thousands
and thousands of years
roughly it would have stayed flat that's
basically the amount of human activity
per person
since the dawn of agriculture
and then
something changes
something changes to make malthus
incorrect
and like most historians he imagines the
future through the past so malthus is
looking back and if that had been the
case if nothing had changed malthus
would have been correct
before capitalism the 99.7 percent of
all human history there was very little
investment there was very little
technological change the world of 1450
looked more or less like the world of
xero
these printers and glassblowers
look like technologies that would have
been legible to the ancient romans and
in fact the largest enterprises in
europe in this period had 40 people
that's the scale of human endeavor in
the moment before capitalism really
emerges and then suddenly things change
things change
and you get to this graph this very
smooth looking graph now i noticed some
of you were nodding your head what do
you notice class about the math of this
graph
i want you to notice the very smooth
flat plane until roughly
the end now it looks very flat because
the end
the period post 1800 is so
vertical
it's very easy to draw this graph even a
robot can do it
and it would be easy to forget that
behind this graph are people
and events
and choices that made this growth
possible that in fact this kind of
growth wasn't possible at any other
period in hundreds of thousands of years
that humans have existed
[Music]
you